the city of San Carlos is once again
bustling with life trade and tourism are
booming with local farmers enjoying the
longest period of calm they can remember
client am move when a delay that are
doing well we're all very much at peace
because no one is scared there's no more
fear the people are much more at ease
but smiles come yet Blanca and her
family returned to their home here one
year ago but although the threat of
violence has receded landmines are still
a constant danger here locals have all
had to learn how to avoid them que no no
TV remote del Camino clay told us that
we shouldn't stray from the path that we
shouldn't touch them please I don't know
he talked more anything that appears
suspicious only a few kilometers away
Bernardo remembers when the people fled
the city lemme just get cara knott
keenest eye does it only two or three
families stayed in this community now
there are at least 13 people feel safe
enough to return to their farm houses
slowly but surely they are coming back
but there are still many yet to return
so much I mean upward you got Bernardo
is now helping the demining teams clear
the fields but first he had to fix his
own farm house abandoned for more than
five years and let me say simpatia 2006
I came back to check on the condition of
my home after a month I came back
permanently yo I've been here ten years
now
the Colombian Army is now working with
several NGOs to clear mines in the
region it's a key part of the peace
process
las perras en otro releases the
humanitarian operation with pro Kadima
they need to consolidate local law and
order to make this area safe it's very
important for the futures was important
so we can make other areas safe no
futuro podemos contar con masturbatory
unfeeling cansados and also support
other people and communities lugar
seguro tres personas por a poder outras
comunidades soldiers are now a common
sight in the towns and villages demining
teams work closely with local farmers
just one was a busy they are our
principal source of information without
them we wouldn't have a reason to be
here no tenemos de como los los medios
electro don't have the necessary
equipment to tell us where the land
mines are algun rincon del moon we
strongly rely on the information
supplied by the locals mkay nozomi mr.
La Mina Palacios fear but even cleared
areas are not a hundred percent safe new
land mines are always being discovered
but local farmers refuse to be
discouraged yo puesta maintain okay I
mean even when they say there are no
more land mines sometimes there are one
or two hidden somewhere but in San
Carlos the area is around ninety percent
cleared here in San Carlos a memorial to
the victims of decades of conflict a
reminder of the horrors of the past and
the fragility of a future peace
you